le moment de la journée que tout le
monde préfère c'est le réveil faut je ne
peux pas te laisser dire ça à l'âne
tu as tout faux le réveil c'est le
moment qu'on déteste le plus je sais
steven c'était de l'ironie
mais bien sûr tu me fais honte alan tu
ne connais rien sur rien je n'ai
vraiment pas digne de reprendre la
société de papa alors là je peux te dire
que j'en connais un rayon sur le réveil
alors ne me cherche pas très bien le
premier qu'il n'aura plus rien à dire de
pertinent sur le réveil ne reprendra pas
la société de papa défi relevé
tu ne me fait pas peur steven et la
thune et carrément plus n'a donc bien vu
[Musique]
je prends la main je t'en prie quel
idiot il n'ya qu'une seule chose à dire
sur le réveil en prenant la main je
gagne forcément il ya quelque chose que
tout le monde utilise c'est l'osmose on
est dégoûtés que notre réveil sonne
alors on le repousse un petit peu et
encore un peu et encore un peu et au
final on se réveille super en retard tu
bien observer il est foutu
il ya un truc horrible avec le réveil 1
c'est quand on fait un rêve
extraordinaire et que soudainement le
réveil sonne le bad
game over alan je ne comprends pas de
quoi tu parles tu viens de faire une
croix sur la société de papa tu n'as
jamais été interrompu dans un rêve
c'est scier du coup tu comprend de quoi
je parle du coup c'est à toi merde oui
je t'écoute
le matin quand on se réveille on a une
haleine de phoques
ça veut dire quoi que les phoques quand
ils se réveillent ils ont une haleine de
nous bonne question tiens j'ai eu très
très chaud mais là il est cuit il ya un
truc embêtant avec le réveil
non c'est impossible il ya plus rien à
dr c'est quand on l'entend pas qu'on se
réveille très en retard qu'on se prépare
en deux minutes qu'on arrive au travail
avec la marque du drap sur la joue et
des crottes au coin des yeux ce n'est
pas du tout pertinent à l'âme
tu penses que cette expérience est
universel mais elle ne l'est pas c'est
vrai steeman personne n'a jamais eu de
crottes au coin des yeux bien qu'à toi à
qui c'est arrivé
j'étais persuadé que ça arrivait à tout
le monde la partie est terminée alors ce
n'est pas la vérité monsieur dominguez
oui en tant que mécanicien de la famille
me dois de rétablir la vérité
steven n'a jamais donné un cadeau certes
mais à part lui tout le monde a des
cadeaux le fait est que la formation des
cadets s'est fait pendant que tous
dehors de l'abri or stephen dans les
yeux ouverts non il ment comme encore à
tort qu'ils gagnent le contrôle de nuit
blanche chaque année c'est vrai style tu
triches steven seagal we are de quoi je
dormais pas
l'info que j'ai dormi c'était il ya deux
jours non
qui de alan de steven reprendre à
l'entreprise familiale
je vous pose une question
c'est une question en fait je vous
demande qui de alan ou de steven va
reprendre l'entreprise familiale
personne ne sait si vous cliquez sur le
macaron ça vous à bonn chaîne multiprise
car les vidéos son rôle estime que c'est
le quatrième membre de multiprises j'ai
un tas d'idées à vous proposer
ça vous dirait de faire une vidéo sur un
serveur dans un bar bush tout chaud tout
simplement parce que j'avais vraiment
que ce à quoi je stressais regarder ma
boîte
[Rires]